a big-name retailer and the AARP or
joining forces to warn us about a
growing scam imposters posing as a loved
one or not a loved one the IRS and
demanding payment with gift cards the
Federal Trade Commission says the number
of cases and these reported scams jumped
two hundred and seventy percent over the
past three years now Best Buy the AARP
and the National Association of
attorneys general are launching a new
PSA to get out the word all the steps
that were being done and taken seemed
real Trinidad Gonzalez is still trying
to face the fact that scammers preyed on
her emotions to pad their own pockets I
gave her my cell number about three
months ago she says a man claiming to be
her grandson called saying he was in
jail and needed thousands of dollars
immediately he didn't put someone on the
phone who posed as an attorney you know
I was hesitant because that's a lot of
money but the caller said he would make
it easy for the 76 year old grandmother
he told her to purchase gift cards from
Walmart and give him the numbers on the
back of the cards he warned her not to
answer questions from store employees I
didn't say anything and they asked me do
you know where this money is going to
and I said it's going to my
grandchildren but the money never got to
her grandchildren that night she figured
out her real grandson was at home in
Virginia by that point Gonzalez who had
recently lost her husband was out four
thousand dollars was too much money too
much money for me to hand over to a
stranger like that I could have paid my
taxes I could have paid all these things
were coming up but to have lost had that
amount of money just just for the sake
of loosing it according to the Federal
Trade Commission twenty-six percent of
scam victims paid with a gift card
between January and September this year
that's up from only seven percent in
2015 it's a huge issue Pennsylvania
Attorney General Josh Shapiro
why wouldn't a scammer just ask for cash
or a credit card number well typically
with cash you'd have to have a meet up
somehow and so they don't want to create
that risk and on a credit card that's
much easier to trace and easier for the
bank to shut down the money flowing to
the scammer so gift cards largely are
untraceable
tackle the growing problem Shapiro
joined forces with New York's Attorney
General and three major retailers last
month Walmart Target and Best Buy
announced steps to try to curb fraud
among them reducing gift card limits
restricting the redemption of gift cards
for other gift cards and enhancing
employee training behind gift cards for
loved ones has Best Buy is taking it a
step further teaming up with the AARP
and a new public service announcement we
certainly see more people start
reporting it because we are empowering
customers now to not be scared about
talking about this they think for a
while there was some shame how hopeful
are you that the campaign can put an end
to this kind of scam we're very hopeful
that shining even more light on it will
help but make no mistake this is a big
industry and scammers follow the money
Trinidad Gonzalez says she was
originally too embarrassed to tell her
friends and family she was scammed now
she hopes her story will put others on
high alert it's very disheartening to
know that you want me to fool them but
now looking back on this I hope it helps
somebody somebody who likes me thinks
they're smart enough not to fall for it
and to question things more cuz I didn't
question anything now the FTC says if
someone calls you demanding to pay them
with a gift card don't the cards cannot
be used to pay for bail or to pay taxes
if you think you've been scammed you
should report the fraud to your card
company and also tell the FTC now
there's one of those stories where you
can put a lock on a door but it's very
hard to put a lock on a heart or a mind
and when you scammers call and they say
your loved ones in trouble it shuts off
your reason there's no doubt about it
and as soon as somebody figures out a
way to shut them down it seems that they
find another way to go after people too